next es la primera gran prueba para los
últimos dos aspirantes en la carrera por
el número 10 de downing street en medio
de la crisis del coste de la vida en
reino unido los primeros intercambios en
el debate entre las tres crisis una que
estuvieron dominados por los
enfrentamientos sobre el gasto haber
turbas daría marcha atrás en la subida
de la seguridad social prometimos no
subirla a nuestro manifiesto en 2019 la
gente aquí que votó a los conservadores
por primera vez espera que cumplamos
nuestras promesas cuestiones
así que la pregunta es debemos pagar esa
factura a nosotros mismos o la cargamos
a la tarjeta de crédito del país y
pasamos la cuenta a nuestros hijos y
nietos para que se hagan cargo ahora
bien no creo que eso sea correcto los
con datos del partido conservador
expresaron filosofías diferentes sobre
los impuestos la actual secretaria de
asuntos exteriores quiere evitar
cualquier aumento
empezaremos a pagarla en tres años eso
no es correcto usted prometió casi 40
mil millones de libras de recortes
fiscales sin financiación el ex ministro
de finanzas dice equilibrar las cuentas
a través de los impuestos ambos
candidatos también se acusaron
mutuamente de no ser duros con china sin
embargo atrás también dijo que le
gustaría que es una que formará parte de
cualquier gobierno futuro un sondeo de
opinión mostró que los votantes
conservadores pensaron que tras ganó el
debate por 47 a 38 por ciento